you are receiving the game-changer award
tonight it's crazy it was a game-changer
in my life my parents that my game
changer is forever and always
yeah totally I mean I was feeling
incredibly nervous I was nervous before
during and after but it was one of those
things where I realized that coming-out
videos for me were such an essential
part of my coming-out process which is
kind of a very modern thing and I really
wanted to give back to that community
and my large community I already had and
help them come out if they needed to or
just preach individuality and make sure
that people know it's okay to be
yourself that was such a great side
effect I didn't I didn't really think
that the video would go viral or
whatever it went but the fact that it
still continues the abuse means it's
been still continuing to change minds
and help people and I think that's great
I'm gonna sob if anyone tells me a story
I will cry I guarantee it
no it's great what it kind of makes it
all worth it when I meet someone a
person they're able to tell me their
personal story and if I'm in some way
helped further that story that's
fantastic I do and I'm so nervous so
nervous oh yeah I wrote it on the plane
the other day they wanted a week ago but
I wrote it yesterday I was so nervous I
didn't know what to say how do you like
how do you sum it all up in one little
speech
don't don't you dare told me that